نيجي لا ايلون ماسك اخبار طرد ماسك
لموظفين في تويتر ما تزال اصدقائها شاغله
المنصه خاصه وانه الاستغناء عن الموظفين
عنده ما توقف لحتى الان وشغال حتى علنا
وعلى تويتر في طرد موظفين بعض اللي طردهم
مؤخرا موظفين اختلفوا معه بالرؤوا بالراي
او ناقشوه في شيء على نان في تغريدات
وتفاجئوا بعدها بامالات استغناء عن
خدماتهم لكن امام كل هذه الاخبار الناس
انصدمت من ساعات بتغريده غير متوقعه من
مصر في ظل الظروف الحليليه ماسك تصور الى
جانب شخصين وعلق وقال ارحب مجددادا
ورجع كده كتب بعدها وقال انه همم مهم
الواحد يعترف باخطائه انه طردهم كان واحد
من اكبر اخطائي زي ما قال ماسك واللي
بيشوف الصوره طبعا بيقول اوف شكله مصر
يعني حس بغلطه بيعترف على الملف لكن اذا
بتدق شويه في الصوره بتبين الحقيقه لو
ركزته شوي في الوجوه اللي في الصوره راح
تحسوا انكم شايفينهم قبل هيك ولو نسيم وين
خليني اذكركم
اللي بنصور ماسكه وهو يرحب فيهم هم نفسهم
الاثنين اللي عملوا مقلب بالاعلام يوم
استحواذ ماسك على تويتر وقفوا قدام الشركه
وعمله انهم مفصولين وطلعوا بالاخر لا
موظفين ولا شيء ووقتها ماسك الشارع في
التنكيت على الموضوع في تغريدات بعد من
فتحت القصه ويعني كثير من وسائل الاعلام
موقف محرج جدا الحقيقه في هذا الوقت عموما
يبدو انه اليوم ماسك حابب يستعين فيهم مره
ثانيه للرد على كل اللي لسه بنتقدوه على
مسلسل الطرد اللي شغال فيه واللي ما وقف
ولا شكله ناوي يوقف قريبا